this is debugging apache spark in python
is for me it's really sad when they
write Python code and get back at JVM
stacktrace
I don't know so I'm really curious how
many people are actively using PI spark
oh my god that's so many people yay I
love you all and I'm really sorry
uh-huh oh god yeah okay cool um so yeah
I'm holding my preferred pronouns are
she or her and I'm a spark emitter as of
January which is really I'm very happy
about this because it's like four years
but whatever I have some spark books as
was mentioned and I will try and get you
to buy the one which I get the highest
royalties on of course and you can
follow me on Twitter it's mostly sort of
complaints as a Canadian living in
America going like what the hell are you
doing but if you want more professional
things the slides from today's talk will
be on my side share and if you want to
pretend to be business people you can
find me on LinkedIn and we can say
business to each other it's I don't know
what it's for but whatever for the
people who aren't already using PI spark
I have some spark videos including an
introduction to PI spark video and
hopefully this talk does not scare you
away from PI spark although with some
farad probably would scare me away
so we normally save the debugging talk
for once we've converted enough of you
and sort of just on a complete tangent I
added this slide after the election in
America I'm trans and queer I'm Canadian
and I consider myself part of the
leather community and like this isn't
super important for software but just
like if you don't know people like me
we're here we're not as scary maybe as
television says we are I don't know what
your television is like but in America
it certainly says a lot of things about
people like me
and I think we're actually really
friendly and so please don't murder us
in our sleep
um and okay cool
moving on yeah I work at the IBM's for
Technology Center I put this slide in so
they keep paying for my travel which is
very nice of them I have this graph that
goes up into the right that shows the
amount of work we do on SPARC and so
it's a very nice graph this also helps
me keep getting paid and so there's
about 50 developers and 25 designers
which is an interesting ratio it's a lot
of fun
if anyone's for some reason looking to
relocate to America come and talk to me
but I imagine that's a tough sell right
now um I don't know maybe you've got
friends there that that's that's that's
legit yeah and here's another slide
which implies we do a lot of work in
SPARC and if you buy something from IBM
whatever it is keep buying it I don't
know I think we sell mainframes and
support contracts and you definitely
want six of those and it's PowerPC or
something anyways yeah cool yeah okay so
I'm hoping you're all friendly people
this is a Python talk and Python people
are normally very friendly so just fake
it if you're not if you objected cats or
stuffed animals this is probably not the
talk for you the other talk looked
really cool and I won't mind if you just
like I like now it's cool and I'm really
excited so many people are already using
PI spark and hopefully you're ok with
things getting a little bit silly
because I don't know how to do serious
yeah so we're going to talk about sort
of how PI spark works behind the covers
um where all the gremlins hide out and
we're going to talk about how this
impacts our debugging we're going to
look at how to find the logs and sort of
how to persist them we're going to talk
about how to add our own logging and
then we're going to talk about trying to
understand the error messages from spark
and that's probably why you're here
and I'm going to try and get you to buy
my new book because I think everyone
should have many copies of it
alternatively we can think about this as
building our monster identification
guide so I like to think that there's a
bunch of monsters hiding out in pretty
much every big data tool chain ever and
so we're going to go this one's boo boo
is a Python stack trace from our driver
program
this one's friend monster friend monster
is the JVM stack trace the JVM sack
trace comes along with every other stack
trace to keep your stack traces from
getting lonely and we brought friend
monster with us today
ambu and then this is tubs tubs had to
say back in America but tubs is out of
memory exception because tubs just like
the eating all of our memory and this is
buddy but he is the really helpful
logging mechanism in spark but likes
telling you things like the sky is still
blue and did you know I'm connected to a
cluster um I don't has anyone had to
turn down the default logging in spark
that's not everyone okay whatever but
yes we all we all know and love buddy
she's very talkative but let's let's
look at how pi spark is built and this
is going to be kind of terrifying kind
of like this playground here right like
I don't think this was actually designed
for children but PI spark is kind of
like if you let your kids play here
Child Protective Services would come and
take them away and thankfully we don't
have that for big data so yeah that's
fun so spark itself is written in scala
for the most part and so pi spark is
actually this really let's call it
interesting solution of bolting Python
on top of that and underneath it and
just trying to pretend as much as
possible that the JVM doesn't exist we
just like close our eyes and say lalala
lalalala
and this is done with PI 4j has anyone
used pi for J well for people that's
really awesome um I love ty for J but
also it's really terrible but it's also
the best thing there is it's it's it's
like most software right like I hate it
because I use it but I also am really
glad it exists but we got really
delightful exceptions from PI for J that
don't make a lot of sense then on top of
we had our own healthy dose of magic and
when the magic works our job finishes
and when the magic breaks were lost
sports sequel avoids some of the magic
that we have to do by just doing a
different kind of magic so instead of
doing this wonderful thing here sports
sequel just like does all of its
computation in the JVM as much as it can
what essentially pi spark works by
having this PI forge a bridge from the
Python VM to a Java VM that distributes
your code out to a bunch of workers that
then has pipes from the JVM to Python
VMs copying your data and then if
anything goes wrong right is essentially
just gets wrapped up in every single one
of these each coming back and telling
you their own little bit of where it
fails inside of this so if I get a
failure inside of here I get like four
stack traces and that's if I'm lucky
right I'll normally get four stack
traces multiplied by the number of
workers I have and then multiplied by
two and that could be like a hundred
workers so I might get 800 stack traces
for like a really simple thing right and
this is this is really overwhelming as a
developer I'm just like what the hell is
going on yeah and so that's why our life
is terrible what we're going to try and
make our lives less terrible the
important one for today is yeah our
message is make no sense and then
there's a bunch of other things that
also sort of impact your life but we're
going to pretend they don't exist for
the purposes of today yeah okay yeah so
one weird trick to debug anything even
though we're working in a distributed
system I think the best thing that we
can do for ourselves is at the start
instead of just jumping right into the
logs and looking at the different stack
traces because it's really easy to pick
the wrong one of the 800 we got back is
building a like kind of shitty mental
model of what we think our code is doing
it doesn't have to be very good but just
like think like what is my program
trying to do and then going and looking
at the logs after you've built that
model
rather than the other way around and
being like oh it's not doing what I
thought it was there is that okay
and yeah just repeating this process a
few times until you give up and go and
become a corn farmer and Iowa or like
just decide that subsampling your data
is okay and whatever big data is a fad
anyways
either one is fine but let's let's look
at where we're going to find our logs so
for those of you that have turned down
your logging level in spark you've
probably been working in Sparks
delightful console and that's the one
where buddy is just going to give us all
of our error messages all of the time
intermixed with messages about every
single like block that is being copied
around the cluster so it's just kind of
really overwhelming but our error
messages are reported to the console
along with a lot of other useless crap
the spark web UI is a lot better place
to find our error messages because it's
sort of not intermixed with all of this
like random logging crap and we can just
focus on the error itself um is anyone
working in Jupiter with spark wow that's
like everyone um and so now this part is
sad the error messages were so useless I
looked up how to disable error reporting
in Jupiter someone told this to me about
like four months ago and it made me
really sad on the inside and I hugged
Boo when we we talked it out and it's
okay um but if you're working in Jupiter
you got this problem where you get error
messages in Jupiter but the part of the
error messages that you get is the part
without the useful information you get
essentially just the error message
coming from this part right here and
everything else that's back here doesn't
really show up inside of your Jupiter
error messages so you just get kind of
sad and you're like I don't this error
messages makes no sense and so it's okay
just go to the random console where you
launched your Jupiter
instance from and you can find your
error messages let's totally intuitive
right and if we're working in the cloud
solution that's really easy to do right
I'll just like ask my administrator to
pass the screen session to me they'll do
that what could go wrong um in all
seriousness if you're working in a cloud
solution hopefully whoever this is has
actually implemented like a correct
solution to this where they pick up the
log messages and actually make it
available to you somewhere if they don't
tell them to look at spark - one nine
zero nine four and steal that code and
then they can make the log messages
available to you or you know just switch
to a different cloud vendor I don't even
know if IBM does this correctly I hope
we do if kids IBM don't switch to a
different cloud vendor how since they're
perfect okay so so for people that are
working in yarn we have to go about
getting our logs in a little bit of a
different way or at least we can yearn
log collection works at least some of
the time in the clusters that I have to
set up myself yarn collection law yarn
log collection work zero percent of the
time in the clusters where I get like a
Hadoop administrator set up for me it
works like at least fifty percent of the
time and then you can just use the magic
incantation yarn log space application -
random string of numbers but is reported
to you at the start and you can get your
logs but really what you want to do is
you want to set up the spark history
server and I should probably stop
wandering off of the podium I'm sorry to
whoever is doing the camera but the
spark History server is amazing it
essentially gives you the spark web UI
after your job is failed and that's
normally when we want to like actually
debug our job right spark by default
what happens is while we're running
we've got this really nice thing I can
click in I can see what's going on with
my workers until my workers fail and
exit and then I can't go look at their
logs anymore and then I'm like wait but
but oh
so you want to turn on the spark history
server and essentially there's five
different knobs that you have to change
and it's different for every one and
you're just going to change those five
knobs until it works and then don't
touch it just don't and hope it never
breaks alternatively for for people
working in yarn you can set this magic
debug delay sex thing to a higher number
and you can just SSH to your container
and like debug it old-school and if
you're finding your yarn log collection
isn't quite working the way you think it
should be try bumping up this number
randomly sometimes it helps magic yay
this isn't all just random [ __ ] to do
but a lot of it is I'm sorry
so yeah spark is very verbose by default
and the first thing that we're going to
want to do now that we figured out where
our logs are is make it so that our logs
contain not just random crap so if you
just need a spark default logging on
it's just going to tell you everything
happening in the world and it's other
mode is telling you pretty much nothing
so it's it has like one big knob with
two settings neither of which are the
one we want but we can use this dynamic
tunable knob and instead of just
changing it in our properties file at
the start of our job we can dynamically
increase the logging to something useful
when we get to the part of our code
where the errors are happening this is a
lot easier to do and makes more sense in
a notebook or an interactive job and if
you're working in sort of a batch job
you're pretty much screwed and you have
to read [ __ ] tons of logs but in
interactive mode a seed upset log level
will let you tone it up when you get to
the part of your code that's failing
okay so what about when we actually get
our error message how are we going to
understand it so yeah but the Python
stack craves and friend monster are
going to be the two things that we focus
on initially oh sorry the JVM stack
trees right so the JVM stack trace comes
because it doesn't want our error
messages to get lonely and for the most
part it doesn't I mean friend monster is
really cute she is but she's not really
useful for the most part the JVM
stacktrace is really just sort of a
carrier that we can ignore but we'll
talk about the kinds of errors where we
actually need to pay attention to the
JVM stack race and we're going to make a
really really simple error and a
transformation and look at sort of how
to find the meat of our exception and
where this all lives so I'm going to
divide by zero this is going to go
poorly dividing integers by zero and so
badness so I know where my error is
because I've started out already but if
like I was doing X divided by Y or
something you know crazy big data stuff
this could go like a lot worse so if I
run this code I get four hundred lines
of exception and if we if we look at
this
at least reading from the top down there
is nothing in here that is useful to me
somewhere in the four hundred lines
there are but it's nowhere near the
start of the exception that I'm getting
back this is all just stuff about sort
of sparks internals that are being
wrapped around our own code that is
telling us about and how these internals
have been impacted by our failure so if
you see things like this don't like
assume it's an error and spark I mean
there's a chance it is but I'll blame it
on you anyways
but like when you see these errors it
probably means your error is actually
hidden deep within so we're going to go
to the spark web UI instead or if you're
one of the fancy people with a spark
history server you're going to go to
your spark history server and so we see
we've got our stage here it failed and
their failure reason is also crap okay
but but there's a thing and I can click
on it and maybe if I click on this thing
I'll get something useful oh my god I
clicked on this thing umm so what we do
is we click on anything and then we can
see okay these are the things that
actually failed on my workers right and
this is probably if I have things that
are failing on my workers
that's probably my problem the error
message that's being reported from my
driver probably isn't what I care about
so it's probably going to be in here and
this is still not very useful but it's
shorter than 400 lines so it's
start then I'm going to scroll almost to
the bottom which is definitely a useable
metric for everyone and then we find our
actual exception you find that I called
my thing bad PI spark because I'm not
very imaginative and we got a zero
division error and if you want to find
this in your own code you actually
search for the magic string or Apache
spark Python exception colon and python
exception is camel case because scholar
developers um yeah and and so that's how
you're going to find the error message
that's happening on the innermost part
of your worker exception and this is
this is pretty easy in this case we
don't even have to really pretend to
make sense of a JVM stacktrace we just
have to ignore it and that's my favorite
thing to do with a JVM stack traces
pretend it doesn't exist it's not going
to work all the time but it's going to
work pretty often for console people you
can like searching your screen session
please don't just use the web UI but you
can search in there and their message is
reported in your console logs but it's
not worth it so why does this error
message make so little sense right like
why do we have when we run this locally
all of this crap coming back to us this
is because we do some really cool stuff
for performance room room and this
performance only costs us when things go
wrong and if we didn't do this cool
stuff for performance we'd lose a lot of
benchmarks so we're not going to stop
doing it because benchmark driven
software development is like that's life
um so essentially what happens is we
need to pipeline our Python code and we
need to do the pipelining inside of
Python in a way that's mostly opaque to
Scala in Scala when we put these two map
transformations together that we showed
on the example of sadness what happens
is this is pipelined inside of scala and
it actually knows which different pieces
executing when it fails inside of Python
what we
the spark Scala Runner is I have a
Python job it contains some code you
don't have to worry about it but just
like run this thing and if we broke this
up into smaller pieces so that we could
see which part of our Python code was
failing easily we would have this
problem where we have to copy the data
from Python into the JVM and sort of
back again twice rather than once and
copying data is kind of expensive even
on a local machine it's going to slow us
down so we do this like sort of
pipelining eagerly inside of Python and
that's why our exceptions are really
confusing but sometimes we've got a
bunch of map transformations chained
together and I don't know which one is
failing right like I don't know why this
thing is going wrong and there's a thing
that we can do we can change our code so
it'll break pipelining while we're
debugging right and then we're going to
take it out afterwards because we want
our code to run wroom wroom fast that's
why we're using spark and what we're
going to do is if you just tag the
intermediate rdd's as cash or persist
spark has to evaluate that entire thing
sort of on its own copy that to the JVM
and then store it in memory and by doing
this it evaluates each transformation
sort of one at a time rather than
sticking them all together and so then
we can figure out which one is actually
failing the other one is you could just
move a take one around that works if
your transformation fails a hundred
percent of the time right like we were
dividing by zero that's going to work
there but if we've got something which
fails on like some of our input data but
not all of it you're probably going to
going to want to do the little cache
thing and move it around so that you can
like actually see which part of your
code is failing the other part is I love
lambda expressions I'm a recovering
functional programming person I still go
to meetings they haven't given me the
chip yet because I keep writing lambdas
all the time and and really the problem
is lambdas are a really fun to write I
don't I don't like writing death and if
I write a lambda I can pretend that I
don't need to test my code it's just a
lambda everything
fine stop asking questions no this
doesn't need a doc string it's really
simple but the problem is lambdas make
debugging hard especially when we have
all of these chained operations together
even if I persist the intermediate rdd's
if I'm using lambdas it's going to be
hard to figure out which piece of my
code is failing so if you find yourself
debugging a part of your code but it's
probably time to rewrite it from lambdas
into functions with names and dog
strings and maybe even tests I'm just
saying
and and I like to say that rewriting
code from lambda to my name function
never broke anything and that's like a
blatant lie
but it's close enough to true that you
should do it anyways and if doing that
rewrite breaks something you were doing
something really interesting that you
should not be doing probably and this is
a good time to stop doing that umm-hmm
yeah please test your code so you
probably don't want to spend your life
looking through JVM stack traces trying
to find the inner Python failures or
wondering about like what this file not
found exception is or why I'm running
out of memory if you test your code you
spend less of your time debugging and
you don't have to get a board the SS
fail boat the fail boat is not a fun
boat to be on it is the boat where my
pager goes off at 2 o'clock in the
morning except now I trip shrink-wrap
software so I don't have a pager but um
in anticipation of when I do have a
pager again yeah you should really test
your code it will make your life a lot
easier and it will help avoid the next
global financial crisis we're in I can
no longer pay my rent so there's a bunch
of different libraries do testing a
spark testing base is the one that I'm a
co-author of and I think it's great
because I'm a co-author of it I don't
make any money on the snow so like I'm
totally fine if you use another one
ebooks will talk but testing libraries
there's there's like two other Python
ones and just pick whichever one feels
more authentic to you whichever one you
really like working with
um yeah so that's great um we've seen
but sparks logging messages are not
super useful so it's probably going to
be time to add our own Java users can
use log4j if there's any like closet
scholar or Java users hanging out here
it's okay we can be friends and I'll buy
you a drink maybe there's not too many
of you and we can reminisce about out of
memory exceptions um Python users used a
logging library there's one called
logging it works in spark it's really
easy you can just use print statements
to I won't even judge you um like just
put something in there don't depend on
spark has anyone used spark accumulators
okay um I really hope none of you do
anything related to finance or things
that impact my life um oh yeah
it's a bit late um but as accumulators
behave weirdly um but they're fine for
debugging because they're debugging if
I'm off by ten percent whatever that's
close enough
um but if you're maybe paying people
with accumulators you might not want to
use it for that um unless you're paying
me accumulators are amazing and we can
talk but you know other people please do
not use accumulators so I think it's
important to distinguish between hard
errors and soft errors everyone who's
ever given me json data has been lying
to me about what the schema is they're
always like this is my schema and I'm
like is it and they're like yeah totally
I'm like is it and then they're like
yeah and then I'm like so I ran this job
and it fails and they're like well I
mean I said it's the schema but like I
gotta go um so what you want to do is
there's a lot of errors where you don't
want to halt your job right you don't
want to throw a spark exception and like
have to debug everything on the other
hand you also don't want to just throw
away all of the invalid records because
one day someone might change their
schema
for all of the new records and then you
know it's maybe it was okay they were
throwing away 5% of your records before
but now you're throwing away 90% of your
records and that's like not really be so
good when they don't get paid like 5%
whatever we can blame it on them or
their banks but 90% like there's going
to be pitchforks in my office
um yeah so accumulators this is the one
like reasonable case for using
accumulators in my mind is we can keep
track of the number of things that I'm
rejecting in this case we're going to
reject everything because I'm just
dividing by zero this isn't super
exciting but if we had some actually
more complex computation inside of here
or we were doing some type of parsing
inside of here we can keep track of our
errors and we can like halt our job if
we get an unexpected number of errors
and we should definitely log what's
going on right like I want to know what
my rejected records were because it's
like I rejected the CEOs thing I'm going
to have to debug it personally later um
but you know it's not too bad we don't
have to halt our job every time we
encounter an invalid JSON record because
if that's my life I'm just going to
spend my entire days cursing the names
of everyone who ever gives me data and
that's not really good for either of us
yeah this is pretty basic to do so why
are accumulators bad essentially
accumulators are bad because of double
counting and double counting here could
actually mean up to J times where J is
defined as the number of actions
performed on any downstream RDD
referencing this kinda and it can change
sort of dynamically it depends like if I
have node failures in my cluster the
counting can increase and so like I can
get J times the number of invalid
records reported to me normally J is
like five and if I have a 5x increase
like that's okay right like I'm
rejecting ten records everything below
100 is fine but if I'm using this for
something important a 5x difference is
going to make a huge sort of change in
my life
um if anyone's really interested in
using accumulators to do useful things I
have a pull request and there's someone
in Chicago who needs to review it and
I'm going to Chicago in two weeks and
you can come with me and try and
convince me to review this pull request
more realistically you can just like
wait a year
but essentially accumulators Wonderful's
regularizing don't use a broad - M tres
don't use it in pi spark it's not going
to work it's very sad
first off it would give us back way too
much stuff the other part is for
internal reasons it's just not going to
work okay so out of memory exceptions
we're going to start to get to the point
where we can't just ignore the jvm
exceptions and this is going to be tubs
tubs is our friend how many people have
had an out of memory exception in spark
how many people have not had an out of
memory exception in spark that you spark
for people you're lucky um so that's
that's really good either you have like
a lot of money or not a lot of data
either one of these is fine um or you're
just like exceptional programmers in
which case San Francisco in that um so
out of memory exceptions are one of the
cases where we get a JVM exception this
can happen a lot during things like
joins will get things like GP time limit
exceeded
has anyone got an application overhead
exceeded I'm sorry
um yeah that can be a wonderful one
because it's an exception message that
doesn't even come from inside of spark
itself it comes from our good friends
over at yarn and we can get an out of
memory exception from the JVM on our
driver program which is very confusing
and let's talk about why these things
are going to happen so we can sort of
recognize what might be going on so on
workers unbalanced shuffles are like a
really big reason for out of memory
exceptions and in PI spark this happens
more commonly because we do some stuff
to sort of save on serialization costs
because pickling is sort of expensive
we do batch serialization and we do some
kind of funky stuff to try and make it
okay but sometimes as previously
discussed the magic fails and then it's
really but sort of on you at this point
to fix it because like I'm not going to
fix it and essentially what happens is
you're going to need to increase the the
number of partitions that are being used
to work around this problem buffering of
rows with PI spark and UDF if you're a
sparks equal user you can get an out of
memory exception by doing a UDF if the
amount of data that is not being copied
to python is really big which is very
confusing because i'm used to thinking
of like out of memory exceptions when
i'm working on too much data but in this
case I can get an out of memory
exception for working on too little data
and that's like kind of not I don't
remember what words I can use and still
be within the code of conduct so I'm
going to not swear but pretend I'm
swearing like a sailor
um so essentially what you need to do in
this case is you're going to select the
subset of data that you want to work
with and you're going to rejoin it with
the RT with the data frame manually to
work around this and this happens
because we do some really cool stuff to
avoid copying all the data that you
don't need to Python just copy the bit
of data that you do need the only
problem is we didn't implement the
buffers correctly and sometimes they run
out of memory and you're going to get an
out of memory exception in this case
jumbo records yeah if you trying to
serialize the world it goes kind of
badly essentially this happens
surprisingly often in SPARC essentially
our classes reference something in some
scope that we weren't remembering and
then spark goes okay I'm going to go
serialize that and then in turns out
sparks you realize all of the records
that were returned from my database and
then I have an out of memory exception
that one's kind of difficult to debug
but if you look in the spark web UI if
or normally the spark history server
because at that point your job is
disappeared in all of your workers of
also disappeared you'll see that the
amount of data being transferred really
doesn't match your expectations and like
that can be totally fine and values of
like 5x to 10x just because of the way
how serialization works but if you start
to see things like a hundred X more data
than you were expecting in your rdd's
like that's probably a good time to go
and look and see if you're maybe
accidentally capturing some extra
information this one's a big one
especially for those people who have had
the application memory overhead exceeded
insufficient memory reserved for Python
workers if you're running in yarn spark
reserves ten percent of the data ten
percent of the memory for your Python
process and keeps the rest of it for the
JVM and sort of miscellaneous stuff and
that's not very useful right you
essentially have to do all of your
computation in only 10 percent of the
memory that's available on your machines
and the reason why this is picked is
that for the most part most people using
spark aren't nearly as cool of all of
y'all and are just writing it in Scala
or Java and so leaving 10% for the
Python VM is like that's fine but for
all y'all you're going to want to change
that to be like 20 or 30% need of code
memory leaks yeah
calling Fortran it's a saying sometimes
I call for training correctly and then
that library from the 1960s just leaks a
bunch of memory and when that happens I
normally try calling a different Fortran
library I tried to debug it once and
that was not on so if you have a native
code memory leak it's going to be kind
of sad but you're also getting its
application memory overhead exceeded
error or like it's going to be killed by
the kernel because it's using too much
memory and in those cases you can just
see that the Python VM is using a lot of
memory not the JVM and then this is
probably what's going on is anyone using
map partitions ok you and I will talk
EFT okay there's two so we'll talk
afterwards because we're running a
little on time but there's some
interesting things about map partitions
for debugging
this is my favorite JVM exception um
because it makes sense I even found a
second one what this is the one that
makes sense so if you try and load an
invalid path in spark you get a JVM
exception and it's the best JVM
exception it says invalid input
exception input path does not exist ah
it told me what happened
it didn't just say there was an error
inside of Map Reduce I mean with org
apache hadoop mapreduce have to skip
reading because it's java but it told me
what went wrong
anyway sorry um so I love this exception
it's really friendly um and this is the
one time that Fred monster just really
comes by herself it's just a JVM
exception and it's a JVM exception that
makes sense
so she just just comes and says hello
and make sure to be her friend she told
you something useful this time for
change
sorry excited monster um okay so we
talked a bunch of out a bunch of random
things and spark we talked about like
why some stuff can go wrong um there's a
bunch of sort of traditional spark
debugging things and a lot of people
might talk about doing if you look at
spark debugging blogs will say things
like look at the dag that's not going to
work so well for Python users because of
the pipelining stuff that we talked
about earlier the sampling data and
running locally is actually really good
for Python users and Java users this is
fine provided that my issue is not
related to the fact that I have big data
and if my issue is actually related to
big data then I'm kind of screwed
we can try connecting a Python debugger
and you're gonna have to change your
code a bit but you can use a broadcast
with a singleton to start a Python
remote debugger and connect to it and it
works at least some of the time if
you're having a Java exception come back
and you're like really adventurous you
can definitely attach a debugger into
Java what that is the passive madness
and so normally I try changing my code
until that doesn't happen
um yeah so the tag is pretty good and
you can use it with your favorite Python
remote debugger and you just use a
broadcast variable with a singleton it's
okay
um here are some books I receive
royalties for many but not all of these
books one of the ones that they don't
receive royalties for that I think is
quite good is called learning PI spark
admittedly my friend receive royalties
for it and I owe him a beer and
hopefully this like absolves us Denny
but yeah it's called learning PI spark
it's by Denny Lee and Tomas it's a good
intro book for most of you you came to a
debugging doctor probably past the intro
to spark stage but if you've got some
friends who are getting started with PI
spark I think it's a good book obviously
I think coming soon high-performance
spark is the best one and you should buy
several copies of it and in fact I will
show you a link to buy it shortly with
um I'm going to do something that
authors don't normally do I'm going to
tell you please don't buy fast data
processing with spark um it's for spark
code seven it's kind of old um I still
get money for it though and the
anti-bribery training told me I can't
receive $20 bills in brown envelopes
anymore so if you just want to like give
me money you can buy several copies of
this book and just like buy the e-book
so we don't waste paper um but you know
whatever but really you should be I'll
be buying high performance spark um
Python is covered in Chapter seven and
there's a debugging section in the
appendix it has such exciting things as
a four hundred line sect race um that my
editor has not yet taken out so buy it
today before she notices um and it's an
early release which means that it's like
you can't buy it in paper yet so will
you have an option to buy it a second
time in paper and yeah if for some
reason you don't want to buy something
but doesn't yet really exist um you can
give me your email address to spam and
spam you I wait oh this is Europe no
selectively contact you in compliance
with EU regulations okay I've got some
upcoming talks if anyone wants an excuse
to visit any of these places you can
come find me if there are any secret
Scala people in the room I'll be giving
some Scala talks as well if anyone wants
to go to Barcelona I'll be giving a talk
there they told me like I could say it
but not to tweet it if anyone has like
an idea of what I should talk about in
Barcelona like please tell me otherwise
I'll just like pick something at random
yeah cool so that's pretty much it